the reason Joe Biden uh is not going
anywhere if he can fog up a mirror it's
because the next person in line is not
is not Gavin Nome uh it's not Michelle
Obama
it's KLA Harris she wants to be
president I read a lot of black media uh
and they feel she's being picked on for
her so-called cackle they feel that Joe
Biden is given her thankless tasks like
getting to the bottom of the root causes
of illegal immigration uh and black
women are the most loyal part of the
democratic base and they will be furious
if she's Drop Kicked uh for anybody
other than a Michelle Obama and Michelle
Obama does not want the job she wants to
be loved she wants to be liked there's
nothing that suggest to me she has a
temperament I want to send her thank you
notes every Christmas for that she does
not have the temperament to be a
politician she she complained for eight
years about what it was like to be in a
fishbowl of being first lady what makes
you think she wants to be a politician
she to be wealthy and influ the play all
Trump supporters must send warm thank
you letters to Michelle Obama but also
include it's we would be upset with you
and we wouldn't love you anymore if you
ran for president